we had to turn to the federal government
for help to to state government for help
i've
i've stood in line for government cheese
i've stood in line for bread and i knew
at 11 years old that that was not
america's best that there was more for
us we didn't live that way in florida
we didn't have to pay with monopoly
money
for groceries in the grocery store and
that's what we were doing in colorado
my stepdad he ended up getting work in
aspen when i was about 12 and we moved
to the western slope of colorado and
that really was the best thing that
could have ever happened to us
we moved into a community
that
wasn't just telling us where to get a
hand out but they were offering a hand
up
we were talking about the californians
coming yes and they're bringing their
bad policies with them and so we there
really is an urban and rural divide and
we want to keep rural colorado rural but
unfortunately in these high mountain ski
resort towns that i represent a lot of
californians can afford to move there
and they're bringing the same policies
that they're fleeing from so i asked
this to every conservative or republican
official that i talked to like when the
people come
do you think they have no idea that they
voted for those policies that they're
now fleeing and realize that maybe they
should think about things a little bit
differently now no i i i mean because
their actions would prove that
they think they could flee from their
problems and unfortunately there is a
lower class
of people who cannot afford to flee
those bad policies that they have voted
in and implemented and so they get to
leave pack up and go to somewhere with
lower taxes and better opportunities and
still have a beautiful scenic view
but there is another class that's left
behind that cannot afford to make that
same move and they are the ones who are
stuck in in
in that
terrible economy and a horrible state
where they are left now to depend on the
government to help uh in their
situations or or
um
even in these failing economies where
taxes are just too high to afford the
homes that they want to live in um so i
mean it's really impacts them more than
anything uh and then they come to these
other states and and bring those same
policies so i wouldn't think that they
knew uh what
impact they are having on these
communities yeah the idea that they're
leaving the people who can't afford to
move is sort of interesting too you know
i realized this morning when i was
thinking about how i wanted to do this
interview that you know if you take sort
of a new crop of congress people
and you think about mostly the democrat
side we all know everything about aoc we
know everything about ilhanomar probably
too much more than we want to know we
know everything about ayana presley and
the rest of the crew but we don't
actually know that much from a national
perspective about you and it's like it
seems like people should be talking
about you just as much
but that's not really how the media
operates because you're a scary
conservative
scary conservative i should be the
democrats dream story i i was raised a
democrat and i i was dependent on
government and i thought i always would
be because when you're stuck in that
cycle of poverty it's really hard to
break free a bit yeah can you tell
everyone your story a little bit yeah
absolutely um so i was born in orlando
florida
my mom was single we lived with her
parents
my grandparents i
attribute a solid foundation to them and
and the few years that they uh that they
had me in their home
but my mom just up and moved us to
colorado when i was four years old she
met him she met a guy and moved to an
apartment in aurora and i think her
pride
was was too big to go back home to her
parents um things kind of got a little
rough he wasn't the prince charming that
she thought he was going to be
but then eventually she had my first
younger brother with him and she didn't
want to have another child not have a
father and so
we were stuck we were here
through the good the bad the and the
very ugly
and that led us to
times where he wasn't working and we had
to turn to the federal government for
help to to state government for help
i've
i've stood in line for government cheese
i've stood in line for bread and i knew
at 11 years old that that was not
america's best that there was more for
us we didn't live that way in florida i
we didn't have to pay with monopoly
money uh for groceries in the grocery
store and that's what we were doing in
colorado
my stepdad he ended up getting work in
aspen when i was about 12 and we moved
to the western slope of colorado and
that really was the best thing that
could have ever happened to us
we moved into a community that
wasn't just telling us where to get a
hand out but they were offering a hand
up and they started sharing with my mom
conservative values
so she listened and even changed her
voter registration to republican
but she didn't vote republican
um
yes yes she
she got to the ballot box and said no
i'm scared i i'll lose everything if
republicans are
in charge we didn't have enough
stability for her to to let go of that
mindset
and so
i started working at 15 years old at the
rifle mcdonald's and i can still
remember bringing mom home that first
paycheck i remember the dignity that had
come with earning a paycheck putting my
hand to something and creating wealth
and that's something that never left me
i learned at a very young age that i
could do a better job taking care of
myself than the government ever had so i
began to develop these
conservative principles not even knowing
what was happening and my husband and i
uh we we met when he moved to colorado
to work in the oil and gas industry
and
you know it
we knew that we could build a great life
together a successful life together i
had only ever wanted to be a mom i
didn't have dreams to to be a business
owner to
be a doctor or lawyer certainly not a
politician
i just wanted to be a mom my mom was my
hero and someone that i looked up to and
so whenever we when we started our life
together we wanted to start our family
right away and
that left me with a very difficult
decision to make my senior year of high
school because now i have a child and a
family and i didn't want to go back to
the bread lines i i didn't want
government cheese for for my boy
and so i quit high school and i took a
management position with mcdonald's that
was very good for my age and uh that was
more valuable they took you into a
management position after quitting high
school just like that yes wow yes no
degree necessary wow
wow yes well it was really
it was the hours that i needed to work
for that shift manager position of why i
needed to quit high school i was working
nights with them and they said to be a
shift manager we need you in this day
shift and so i had to leave high school
to
to take on that role and for me there
was
um there was more value in earning that
paycheck for my family than sitting in
geography class for another two months
until i graduate high school do you
remember what you were making per hour
at that point 45 a year 45 a year 45 000
a year oh that's points you were in the
management position but do you remember
what you were making per hour at
mcdonald's about 7.50 so there was there
was um there was
several different pay periods that i had
with them i started out i think at 6 15
an hour and then i was about 7.50 an
hour and then i went to a salaried
position
how much of that shapes your economics
the way you think about it now because
you know to be a good person i thought
we have to have everyone making or the
lowest people have to make 15 that means
you're a good moral person if you scream
that should you have been making 15 an
hour then no i worked for every extra
dollar that i did earn um and
it really gave me an opportunity that i
wouldn't have had if minimum wage was 15
look at how how many things are
automated now
now that we're we're reaching 15 per
hour mcdonald's has kiosks instead of
the 15 16 17 year old high school
student that was coming in and earning a
paycheck and so i would not have had the
opportunities that have shaped my world
view my economic view had minimum wage
been so high because they would not have
been able to afford to invest in me and
provide that opportunity for for me to
to have a work ethic and and develop my
life skills if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell